while following the news about space
exploration
we pay more and more attention to
objects lying really far away from our
planet
but apart from remote stellar systems
there are other
celestial objects lurking in the
universe which are even more mysterious
and unlike most some of them are
actually getting closer to our planet
rather than receding from it imagine a
celestial body reaching out to us
whose journey began somewhere beyond the
boundaries of our
system and in violation of all notions
about astronomical bodies traveling in
space
this one is moving right at us the
entire scientific community would be
utterly baffled
on discovering an interstellar
interloper like that
and today i'll tell you about the most
bizarre objects
ever to have come comparatively close to
our planet
generally speaking celestial bodies with
such parameters
fall into the category of interstellar
objects
interestingly they're usually not
gravitationally dependent on any star
and are quite free to choose their own
course
in theory such space wanderers may come
from asteroid belts of other stellar
systems
and then after they collide with a
larger object
their orbits may change this makes them
break away from their native systems
the same mechanism of producing
interstellar space objects
is applicable to our system too the
greater number of bodies from the oort
cloud and the kuiper belt
eventually end up in interstellar space
bearing this in mind it seems reasonable
to assume that there is a much greater
number of objects in our system
that originally come from somewhere in
deep space than thought earlier
for example on rare occasions
interstellar interlopers may be captured
by the gravitational pull of a larger
celestial body
then they may be influenced by the sun's
gravity that will lock them on a
heliocentric orbit
the only closest planet able to perform
this on account of its impressive mass
is jupiter it is in the environs of this
gas giant that a comet can be found
which is one of the most unusual short
period comets
ever detected in the solar system
[Music]
spotted on the 12th of may 1986
the comet was dubbed 96 p magholz 1.
the object's peculiar characteristics
are its most unique features
to start with the comet's orbit is
exceptionally elongated
which allows it to approach the sun as
close as .123 astronomical units
just to compare this is two and a half
times smaller than mercury's perihelion
its chemical composition is another of
its unusual characteristics
it contains 72 times less cyanogen
than any regular comet these properties
give astronomers grounds to suppose that
mcholz1 was born
far away from the boundaries of our
system having been captured by jupiter's
gravity
it was indeed brought into heliocentric
orbit
nevertheless mack holtz one remains a
hypothetical interstellar interloper
whose origins are in essence quite
untraceable today
meanwhile there are thousands of comets
and asteroids already known to us
and among them there are some
astronomical bodies that have arrived to
our system comparatively recently
one of these is the comet known as 2i
borisov whizzing through our system at
30 kilometers
per second this object is
gravitationally independent from the sun
the comet to eye borisov is likely to
have set out on its long journey from
the cassiopeia constellation near the
border with the perseus constellation
there are several points in space that
claim the title of the comet's parent
stellar systems
ros 573 gj4384
and hd 34327
as for the comet's characteristics that
have been found out so far
its diameter measures 20 kilometers and
its orbit is hyperbolic
at the same time the comet's spectrum is
very similar to that of most other
comets in the solar system
the celestial object is consistently
observed
two consecutive flares were registered
on 2i borisov in early march
2020 by astronomers from the ogle
project team
the processes suggested by these
telltale manifestations
are indicative of an explosion in the
comet's interior
with a large fragment ejected as a
result
however nothing is known about what
happened to the newly formed
chunk even in spite of the uniqueness of
the comet
2i borisov it is quite logical that such
like celestial objects
do exist sooner or later an object like
that was supposed to pass through our
system
but it is hardly possible to say so
about another celestial body we'll be
looking at
namely about the first interstellar
asteroid
ever detected dubbed
the asteroid was detected on the 19th of
october 2017
by the canadian astronomer robert
werwick the object was 30 million
kilometers away from the earth at that
time
at first omuamur was mistaken for a
comet
but later it was reclassified as another
kind of celestial body
a hyperbolic asteroid it is highly
likely that the starting point for the
object's travels was an environs of the
vegas star
and then it set out towards our system
following a hyperbolic trajectory and
moving at a speed of 26 kilometers per
second
scientists cannot say how long aomo amur
may have been racing through
interstellar space
and for all we know the solar system may
be the first planetary system the
asteroid has visited
after its ejection from the parent
system
the object is posited to consist
predominantly of rock
and its diameter is estimated at
approximately 200 meters
being cigar shaped the asteroid may
rightfully be called one of the most
elongated objects in the solar system
according to the astronomer david jewett
it is a shape
that mainly draws scientists attention
the reason for that
is that a celestial object with such
peculiar looks
must have some unique story of its
origin having formed either as a result
of a destructive event
or else artificially for example
at some point of its existence omuamua
may have been a shard of a
protoplanetary body
with the latter having approached its
native star too close
and ultimately having been torn apart by
its tidal forces
computer modeling of such events
revealed that there is a large celestial
body within several hundred thousand
kilometers from its star
it may really be destroyed under the
influence of stellar tidal flows
this makes it disintegrate into
exceptionally elongated bits
whose kinetic energy allows them to
leave their system
this event is thought to have happened
approximately 45 million
years ago this spurred some scientists
to put forward another hypothesis
they maintained that in theory this
object might actually turn out to be a
spaceship
constructed by an alien race to
futurologists deep regret
astronomers closed the case in 2019
proving once and for all that there is
absolutely no evidence in support of the
hypothesis
that omuamua was created artificially
at the moment the asteroid is on an
escape trajectory from our solar system
heading towards the pegasus
constellation the velocity at which it
is racing away from the sun
has proved to be slightly higher than
had been predicted by applying celestial
mechanics
laws the value reached around 31.6
kilometers per second
on the 1st of june 2018
hypothetically it will be possible to
send a mission to this asteroid
this would allow us to find out more
about its properties
however no existing spacecraft would be
able to catch up with omuamur
as the speed at which it is streaking
through space is too high
in theory it is feasible to get close to
the asteroid after a gravity boost
maneuver
performed near jupiter and thanks to the
oberth effect
which is supposed to greatly boost the
engine's acceleration
more advanced options for the purpose
are considered as well
among these scientists suggest using a
laser pushed light sail
based on the breakthrough starshard
technology
however it should be noted that the main
challenge that will have to be tackled
in the course of the missions
will be to reach the asteroid in as
little time as possible
while at the same time to be able to
collect valuable scientific data
if on the other hand the spacecraft
accelerates too much
it will not go into omar moore's orbit
and will simply whip past it
and fly on and so today investigating
the asteroid with the help of spacecraft
remains just a theory
if a mission of this sort does get
launched sometime
it is hard to imagine what secrets
lurking in the celestial body may be
revealed to us
having negotiated millions of kilometers
on our travels
objects like omuamua are bound to be
sources of staggering amounts of
valuable information
no one can tell what events they may
bear traces of
in addition to that interstellar
interlopers may in theory
turn out to be the carriers of varieties
of matter which are unknown to us
if mankind is able to reach the surface
of one of these objects
a mission like that might well find
answers to many questions
about these mysterious celestial
travelers
[Music]
you